>> Sean: BREAKING NEWS TODAY
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
THREATENING TO READ RETALIATE
WEDNESDAY AFTER THE CHINESE
CLOSED A CONSULATE IN HOUSTON,
TEXAS.
CONCERNS IT WAS BEING USED FOR
ESPIONAGE.
THIS AFTER THE DOJ ANNOUNCED IT
HAS CHARGED TO CODE CHINESE
HACKERS WITH TRYING TO STEAL
UNITED STATES CORONAVIRUS RESEAR
HERE WITH REACTION LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY.
YOU HAVE BEEN VERY OUTSPOKEN ON
THIS.
LOOK, THE FACT THAT AFTER ALL OF
THESE YEARS THAT WE HAD PEOPLE
30 AND 40 YEARS AGO HACKING INTO
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
WE DON’T FIX THIS ANNOYS THE
LIVING DAYLIGHTS OUT OF ME.
WHAT POINT IS THAT OUR PROBLEM
AND OUR FAULT?
SPEAK WITH THE COMMUNIST PARTY
IN CHINA HAS BECOME A WORLD
COMORBIDITY.
AN AMERICA ALLOWED IT.
FOR WELL OVER 20 YEARS.
TOO MANY OF OUR LEADERS GOT UP
EVERY DAY AND JUST TOOK THE
BULLET TRYING TO -- WE DIDN’T
STAND UP TO CHINA.
NOW, WE ARE.
AND WE ASKED OTHER COUNTRIES TO
JOIN WITH US.
I DON’T WANT A WAR WITH CHINA.
CHINA SAYS THE COMMUNIST PARTY,
SAYS IT WANTS RESPECT.
YOU HAVE TO EARN RESPECT.
RESPECT IS NOT A PARTICIPATION
TROPHY.
THEY HAVE TO SHOW THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO BE POSTED
STAKEHOLDERS IN A STABLE LAW AND
ORDER.
AND VERNACULAR THAT MEANS THEY
HAVE TO STOP CHEATING.
>> Sean: INNOCENT PEOPLE DIED
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THEIR LIVES.
THEY NOW WANT TO STEAL OUR
INFORMATION.
THE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THEFT
HAS BEEN A HUGE PROBLEM.
TRADE IMBALANCE A HUGE PROBLEM.
WE MUST NOW REMOVE ALL OF THE
MANUFACTURING FOR VITAL ITEMS
LIKE PHARMACEUTICALS AND
MEDICINES.
WHAT DO YOU PROPOSE WE DO?
>> THE FIRST THING THAT I WOULD
DO IS ASK OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
WESTERN WORLD TO JOIN WITH US.
AUSTRALIA IS ALREADY THEY ARE.
THE UNITED KINGDOM IS ALREADY
THERE.
BUT I’M THINKING SPECIFICALLY OF
OUR FRIENDS IN EUROPE, THE E.U.
IT IS TIME THAT THE E.U. GREW
SOME ORANGES AND SAID, YOU KNOW,
WE STAND FOR SOMETHING.
IT’S BEEN WHEN THEY ARE WEAK.
>> THEY ARE WEAK.
>> AND THEY COULD BE MUCH
STRONGER.
BUT THEY ARE SO WORRIED ABOUT
MAKING MONEY FROM AND WITH
CHINA, THAT IN MY JUDGMENT, THEY
SACRIFICED THEIR VALUES.
I DON’T MEAN TO OVERSTATE IT.
THERE HAVE BEEN A FEW COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE PUSHED BACK, BUT THEY
NEED TO PUSH BACK AS A GROUP, AS
AN ORGANIZATION, PARTICULARLY IN
GERMANY.
>> Sean: WELL, I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING.
PEOPLE IN YOUR STATE IN EVERY
STATE IN THIS COUNTRY DIED
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY DID.
AND AROUND THE WORLD.
WHY WOULDN’T PEOPLE UNITE ON
THAT?
WE HAVE ABOUT 20 SECONDS.
>> IT IS NOT JUST A CORONAVIRUS.